there about a 4 second Plus game shot
clock difference yeah they're not going
to
foul Portland does have a foul to give
if they have to foul they have to foul
twice well if they make the shot it'll
still be one position game unless they
make it three Curry
three asabuki doing play before play I
think that's what Steph was thinking
when you're down one you can't give up a
three cuz a four-point lead is a
two-possession game and there's only 9
seconds left think about it when you're
in a one-point game Austin Reeves hit a
three last night it's the new NBA you
can't give up a three there because now
you're down four aony Simons could have
just got up on him right on his body and
force him to drive you got you got to
run the guy off the three-point line but
they clearly weren't thinking and I
don't know if anyone was telling him
that this is Steph Curry's reaction
afterwards he was super hyped but
remember when Steph
Curry